I shall force by United Nations troops
in an effort to avoid an all-out war
between traders and their former militia
protectors in bangies pk5 neighbourhood
the area was once described as one of
the most volatile districts in the
country now the United Nations has
stepped in calling on both sides to
disarm anyone seen with arms will be
arrested disarmed or neutralized if he
or she resists the population shouldn't
take law into their hands it's the
responsibility of Anushka and local
forces we will also occupy in control
bases of self-defense groups for
government forces this is the first time
they're setting foot in pq5 since 2014
no much to pretend about the current
situation if one is a trader you're a
trader if you're a militia man
we will reintegrate you to work last
week clashes broke out between traders
and a local militia protecting them over
accusation of extortion more than 40
people were killed days later the
traders vowed to chase the militia out
of the area the Declaration of the pk5
neighborhood as a weapons free zone came
just hours before a deadline to
surrender all arms in the neighbourhood
expire traders who had earlier relied on
militiamen for protection had told them
that they need to surrender all weapons
in their position or face an all-out war
now a shooter side order has been issued
on anyone seen carrying a gun in this
level
disarming fighters which the United
Nations want to carry out is something
no one was able to do in pk5 since the
outbreak of civil war in 2013
some residents wary of the bloodshed
hope this time it will be different our
message is clear people should really be
careful we are going to make sure no one
is using guns to hold people to ransom
people were fed up and disappointed with
what the vigilantes were doing that's
why they weren't the presence of
international and local forces to take
charge and guarantee everyone's safety
for now a bloody confrontation
New Year's Eve is averted but no one
knows for how long this piece will hold
a Hamid Idris al Jazeera Bangi